parents are fighting for answers after
at least seven children were recently
diagnosed with cancer in one California
community we showed you their push to
remove a cell phone tower earlier this
year now they are focusing on a chemical
in the drinking water that's linked to
cancer Carter Evans visited ribbon
California which is just one of dozens
of cities across the country dealing
with the possibly harmful chemical until
we figure out what is happening in this
town we won't stop
Kelly Prime's son Kyle is one of at
least seven kids in Ripon California
who've been diagnosed with cancer over
the last four years she and another bomb
first removed his cell phone tower from
a local elementary school campus now
they're taking a closer look at a
dangerous chemical found in the town's
water supply my gut tells me that
something is here that's causing these
issues this site in Ripon was once home
to a Nestle plant that used
trichloroethylene or TCE
to decaffeinate coffee until the 1970s
Nestle discharged the plants wastewater
into the city sewers the company says
for more than 30 years they have
implemented cleanup and water protection
measures to ensure levels do not exceed
California Standards TCE was recently
found in one of five city drinking water
well this is the well where they found
that CCE the city of Ripon says TCE
levels reached 90% of the EPA maximum
allowed in drinking water last summer
the well was turned off four months
later the city says the water meets all
established drinking water standards
University of California San Francisco
scientist veena Singla says when it
comes to chemicals like TCE there are no
safe levels of exposure drinking water
standards and guidelines that we have
now are many decades old and they don't
account for the latest science that
shows that pregnant women and children
are more susceptible to TCE
millions of pounds of TCE are used every
year for manufacturing and decreasing
the chemical can migrate from industrial
sites into surrounding communities
through the soil and water it can even
turn into a
clear odorless vapor that moves up into
the homes above we know it can cause
cancer by any route of exposure so what
that means is whether you breathe it in
whether you drink it and contaminated
water we're concerned about all of those
exposures do you think that this is
something that could have caused your
son's cancer I think that it needs to be
looked into for sure last year we
visited Franklin Indiana where dozens of
kids were diagnosed with cancer a
nonprofit found high levels of toxins
including TCE vapor in homes near an old
manufacturing site cleanup and testing
under the EPA is ongoing Kerry Reinhart
lost her daughter to brain cancer
we used our kids as a canary in the coal
mine in our town and in White Bear
Township Minnesota community members
diagnosed with cancer and their loved
ones were outraged after learning a
company that makes fishing sinkers and
battery terminal posts admitted TCE had
been leaking into the air for years and
points reaching seven times what was
allowed in Ripon families are calling
for additional vapor testing we have a
lot more questions than we do answers so
until we get those answers to those
questions we are very concerned
regulators say potential health effects
from TCE depend on the amount and length
of exposure and it can be difficult to
trace the cause of any one cancer
diagnosis but prime says after seeing
her son's battle firsthand she'll do
anything to prevent other parents from
experiencing the same pain hell I mean
it was
it's life-altering it sick every day
losing weight losing its hair your son's
in remission now what keeps you going
the fight that these kids have in them
like we have to show them that we will
fight for them for CBS this morning
Carter Evans Ripon California the
Regional Water Board has asked Nestle to
do additional vapor testing to ensure
TCE levels are within new stricter
guidelines set by the state Nestle says
the work plan has been submitted and
approved by the water board can't
imagine I mean losing a child so young
and then that fight in you to find out
what's wrong
yeah what's going on in the community
yes apparent you watch your kid gain
weight and then when they start losing
weight tariffs just terrifying